[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: To get started with
the Cloud Natural Language API
for Node.js, you'll need
a GCP project, which
you can set up in the console.
Next, enable the Google Natural
Language API for that project.
Then create a service account
and download the private key
as JSON.
You're going to use
these credentials
to access Google Cloud APIs, so
keep this file secure and out
of your code in public repos.
To access the credentials
from your project,
go to the terminal and set
an environment variable
to the path of your
service account.
Prepare your environment
for Node.js development.
Then install the client library.
If you use Cloud
Shell in the console,
you can skip the step since
the required dependencies
are already included.
Make a new project file
or open an existing file.
Import the Google
Cloud client library,
and then instantiate a client.
Provide some text to analyze.
I'm going to go with a
classic example here.
Now create a document which
has a field called content
set to the text
you are analyzing
and a field called type,
which, as the name suggests,
is the type of text--
in our case, plain text.
Call analyzeSentiment,
passing the document.
This function returns a
premise I'm calling results,
which resolves to an array.
The first element of the array
is an object representing
analyze sentiment response.
Analyze sentiment response
has three properties--
document sentiment,
the overall sentiment
of the input document--
language, the
language of the text--
and sentences, an
array of sentiment
for each sentence in the text.
Define a constant for the
sentiment of the document.
Log the parameters of
sentiment score and magnitude.
Score is a sentiment
score between negative 1
for negative sentiment
and positive 1
for positive sentiment.
Magnitude is a number
between 0 and infinity
which represents the
absolute magnitude
of the sentiment regardless
of positive or negative score.
Finally, include a catch
block to handle any errors.
Save this file and run the code.
If everything
worked properly, you
should see the original
text, a sentiment score,
and a magnitude in the terminal.
If not, take a look back at
the code for any syntax errors.
Congratulations, you've
just sent your first request
to the Natural Language API.
But there is more that the Cloud
Natural Language API can do,
like analyzing syntax
and annotating text.
To find out more about
the client libraries,
consult natural language basics,
or work through this sentiment
analysis tutorial, check
out the Cloud documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]